during my graduation we were taught
traditional advertising but the industry
demanded digital skills so finding a job
in the digital marketing domain was a
challenge for me I thought a
certification in digital marketing would
help me get a job and it did after the
course I was hired by pantelin as a
digital media specialist with a 20
salary hike and now I'm finally doing
what I like hey I'm Isaiah Moore I live
in Arizona and the United States I did
my graduation in 2020 in strategic
Communications from Northern Arizona
University in 2020 I joined Nova Home
Loans as a trailing documents
coordinator and worked there for almost
a year in fact I worked at various
places as a student but after graduation
I couldn't find a job in my field of
study or anything that aligned with my
interests I gave tens of interviews but
without any luck
the reason
I lacked practical skills on top of that
I had no certification in digital
marketing in particular
so last year I decided to upskill myself
with a professional certificate program
in digital marketing offered by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University I think it was a very good
decision I really liked the curricula it
helped me enhance my Knowledge and
Skills last year itself after the course
I was hired by panalope as a digital
media specialist with a 20 salary height
and this year I was promoted to digital
marketing account
I finally found my footing in the
digital marketing domain and I think the
certification had a huge role to play
this certification helped me pursue my
desired career path I can use my skills
and experience to become a freelance
digital marketer one day upskilling has
helped me turn my dream into a reality
[Music]